for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
okay so in this video we're going to
figure out the electron configurations
specifically the ground state electron
configurations and the orbital diagrams
for all the elements in the first two
rows of the periodic table so if you
have a periodic table handy great if you
don't grab one and pause this video and
then go grab one come back to it so all
we really need from the periodic table
is the atomic number of each of these
elements because that's going to tell us
the number of electrons okay and we're
going to use the op op principle to help
us realize which orbitals are filling in
first and then next and so on and so
forth so we're going to start off with
hydrogen hydrogen has an atomic number
of one and thus one electron and the
first orbital that we're going to fill
is the 1s orbital right because we alpha
the Aufbau principle 1s is first and
then there's 2s and 2p and 3s and we're
actually not going to really go further
than to pee in this video so I'll just
stop there for now so hydrogen one
electron so it's going to be 1 s 1 okay
and the orbital diagram for that in the
1s orbital here we're going to have one
electron that would be it next up is
helium Z of two so two electrons so 1 s
2 so the 1s orbital will have one up and
one down lithium three electrons now we
can't put one s 3 because s can only
have two electrons maximum so we're
going to have one s two and then we have
to move to the next orbital which is the
2's orbital according to the Aufbau
principle so it's going to be 2 s 1 for
a total of three electrons so we're
going to have in the 1s it'll be filled
and then we'll move on to the 2's
orbital I'll put one there beryllium
four electrons so 1s2 2s2 and so now the
2's orbital is filled in addition to the
one answer a rule next up is boron five
electrons so we'll have 1 s2 2 s2 and
then we now can put one in the 2p
orbital right
total of five electrons so the 1s is
filled to s is filled so that's four
electrons there one more will go to the
2p so we just begun to the 2p orbitals
here now we have three two P orbitals so
carbon 6 electrons so we're going to
have 1s2 2s2 2p2 so 1 s is filled 1 2 2
s 3 4 and now we got two electrons in
the 2p orbitals so we're going to go one
and then two so this is the first time
we're going to apply hund's rule here
right because we have to have feel all
the orbitals first right actually not
going to do like that this is where
we're starting off with hund's rule
right we have to have fill the electron
the atomic orbitals with electrons
before we start doubling up next up
nitrogen if you have seven electrons so
1s2 2s2 2p3 for a total of seven
electrons so one two three four five six
seven electrons right they're all half
filled now so that's also an application
of hund's rule they're right next up is
oxygen so we got eight electrons so we
got 1s2 2s2 2p4 so the 1s is filled to s
is filled of the 2p orbitals we got one
two three and then we can go back I'll
begin to double up with 2 p-4 okay so
hund's rule again fluorine 9 electrons
to s2 or Jimmy 1s2 2s2 and then 2 p-5 so
it's nine electrons 123456789 the neon Z
equals 10 10 electrons to us or 1s2 2s2
and 2 p-6 so 1s is filled to us is
filled and even the 22 p it's also
filled one two three four
56 so we've filled all of the orbitals
with neon a noble gas super important
actually keep that in mind noble gas
filled configuration filled orbitals now
I got a question down here what is the
set of quantum numbers associated with
the electron with the arrow pointing to
it so this electron right here what are
the quantum numbers associated with it
so it's asking basically what the L
value core what the n value is what the
L value is what the M sub L value is and
what the M sub s value is well within
the it's n is 2 here except to 2p so the
n value is to the L because the P is
equal to 1 the M sub L it's in the third
overall here so if we think about these
orbitals specifically we've got negative
1 here 0 here and positive 1 here so the
M sub L value there is positive 1 let's
keep that in green actually the M sub L
value there is positive one and it's
spinning downward so minus one half so
this here is the home address for that
specific electron so I hope that video
was helpful thank you for watching if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying